so this is the first batch of Tesla's to
hit the UK and you expect him to sell
35,000 of them this year 11 years ago
the company didn't exist what were you
thinking when you founded it well when
we created Tesla we wanted to show that
you could make a really compelling
electric car that that you could make an
electric car that was really better than
a petrol car and I think with the Model
S we've been able to achieve that it's
been rated by by some of those critical
reviews in the world as as being among
the best mitten and some by some the
best car in the world and what's been
the biggest challenge over there's 11
years making this a thing over 11 years
Wow okay there's a lot of a lot of
challenges I mean the the biggest
challenge that Tesla faced was not going
bankrupt in 2008 when that with the
global financial crisis you know General
Motors and Chrysler went bankrupt and we
narrowly avoided bankruptcy thanks to a
dedicated group of employees and
investors that was probably our most
difficult to moment in the creation of
this kind particular I suppose the most
challenging thing was to create a super
safe car that had great performance and
and yet had had great range as well so
the cars got a turn 65 mile range
despite being a luxury sedan with with
the transponder capability and on that
safety point as soon as there's any
there's a small incident last year I
think with Tesla the press jumped on it
do you think the reporting around it is
fair do you feel like as soon as well I
think Tesla gets a lot of attention
positive and negative and I guess it's a
bit of live by the sword die by the
sword
you know that everything we do seems to
be amplified and and you know there were
thought there was no sort of fire thing
which and even though the Model S
has an incidence of fire which is five
times less than the automotive industry
in fact it might have I think it's maybe
the least fire-prone car on the market
last year it got more press than the
other 500000 gasoline car fires combined
and even though we've never had an
injury I mean touchwood we've never had
a serious permanent injury at any of our
cause
ever nobody's died nobody's had a
permanent injury in any of our cause
ever you know I think there may be still
some perception that that our car is is
somehow not safe even though it's
actually the safest part of the road and
is that coming from the manufacturers do
you feel like you're up against these
big established incumbents and they're
sort of scared they're taking swipes at
you
some of them do take swipes yeah and I
suppose that's natural for competitors
yeah but I think the truth wins out in
the end particularly these days with the
internet there people are able to search
and compare and and you know with with
five minutes of research you can get to
the truth very quickly you're very quick
to come back online as well occasionally
when it's yeah are you monitoring are
you quite thin skinned about this stuff
well I mean I really care about Tesla
and about the Model S and everything so
it's hardly dispassionate about that you
know it's it's a lot of blood sweat and
tears from a lot of people and you I
think particularly if the criticism
isn't accurate you know it's sort of
like the Model S is it's like your child
you know it's like and it's like like
this your child goes into a competition
and and loses but not for not on the
merits then you'd be pretty angry about
that you know or or if if you know
somebody disparages your child in a way
that's that's that's false I mean you
know they're they're honest criticisms
to be to be had certainly but but
it's difficult to take pulse prism of
something you care about and interact so
it's taken a new company against
incumbents it's also in terms of green
think we've had we had a lot of talk in
the UK about green thing it's kind of
slipped off the agenda why is it taking
a private company to bring it back to
the agenda and is the government really
thinking about this enough have you
found that that you're kind of fighting
against this well I mean governments
around the world certainly make a lot of
noise about caring about the environment
but the results are not very good
particularly in automotive you know that
there's much less than 1% of new cars
made every year are electric and so as
well as this year to be 90 something
million cars made a year so rounded-off
say 100 million new cars made a year
there's about 2 billion new car 2
billion cars in the global fleet even if
all cars weren't to elect were elect or
all new countries were electric this
year
it would take 20 years to replace the
global fleet yeah and and much less than
1% of new cars made this year are our
electric so clearly we need stronger
action yeah and if you take the
government's is the UK government needs
to do more here I think all governments
need to do more American government UK
government and I know they keep sort of
talking about it but but we really need
I mean really the action needs to be
ratcheted up until we see solid movement
towards electric cars I mean how about
at least 1% of cars being made or
electric that seems like a very low bar
one of those bars they I mean we're
standing here in front of this car and
this is I think about 85,000 pounds to
buy well this particular configuration
they start at 50,000 pounds that's
probably got lots of options and things
you can go guys examples an affordable
50,000 buzz but that's how the reach of
most people is it it's great it's lovely
to talk about the environment and saving
it you know is it just a plaything for
the rich there
this point well the goal of Tesla is to
create mass-market electric cars but we
can only get there one step at a time
and we started off with the Roadster
that a sports car which was even more
expensive and a very low volume now
we're in step two which is would argue
is sort of a mid price
mid volume car and but we need to sell
this car in order to make the money for
the high-volume affordable car in the
future
it's even we can't think of any other
way to get there when when will we get
that high volume affordable car do you
think it's about three years three years
away and then we'll be driving the lamp
okay that's great but then beyond that
is necessarily car the best paradigm for
this for you to transportation says so
you've suggested yourself the Hyperloop
we've seen the Google driverless cars
different forms of public transport is
the car it sort of an old metaphor why
do that rather than think of something
completely new
well people people like cars really
that's what that's their chosen method
of getting around and you know so we
have to adapt to our people want to do
that's not to the exclusion of something
like the Hyperloop or mass transit but
it's complimentary certainly and so
we've got to got to make electric cars I
think it's
yeah yeah I don't know around the time
you found it Tesla will say same sort of
time founded SpaceX yeah another company
sex was about a year year earlier but
yeah okay so that was a busy efe take us
through that I mean ammonia test and
then SpaceX what was what was your idea
with SpaceX well with space actually the
goal is to accelerate the development of
rocket technology so if you think about
the fact that humanity was able to go to
the moon in 1969 and now can sort of
barely get to low-earth orbit that's
that's that's not even I mean that's a
huge decline in capability and what we'd
like to do with SpaceX is try to turn
that around and rapidly improve rocket
technology to the point where maybe
ultimately we could have a city on Mars
and be a multi-planet species
I'm not saying SpaceX gonna do all that
but we were going to try to advance
rocket technology as much as we can in
that direction and what were you know
there was the latest on that well right
now we're so we're launching quite a lot
of satellites into orbit for various
commercial customers where NASA's our
single biggest customer they're about a
quarter of our launches and we've done
missions to and from the space station
with cargo including live cog in some
cases so our next mission to the space
station will include 40 mice sort of
astronauts and it has the ability to -
it maintains a life-support system
everything will be launching astronauts
in about two years and and keep going on
from there now you say it's you know 60
years since the moon how disappointing
is it the government's that you know
private industry has to step in here why
governments backed away and is it a pity
that they've backed away yeah well I
mean I think what we're doing at SpaceX
is certainly in collaboration with NASA
NASA's been a big supporter and I'm not
sure we could have really gotten to
where we are today without NASA
but in general sort of a commercial
technology companies are better in
advancing technology than governments
particularly once it gets out of the
sort of fundamental research phase and
that's that's sort of what SpaceX hopes
to be is sort of to to really drive the
technology development a lot faster than
would occur otherwise who was just sort
of a big of an endeavor oh yeah and yeah
you're gonna get for an asteroid first
or Mars purse what's that um to the moon
in about that's true first of us well
there's not many asteroids between here
and Mars that are any you know of any
size so far as is the case of
destination do that after you good after
the moon you're either going to go to a
very small asteroid or Mars the big
asteroids are between Mars and Jupiter
that's great so you've got your eye on
them already
is there a rough date for the Mars
landing in your mind but 11 or 12 years
11 or 12 years cool that's great and but
it's at the same time you say private
companies can step in and do this is
there danger with the privatization of
space so people have to call it the Wild
West the Wild West was famously the most
ruthless example of capitalism fo is
very hard a lot of people may might is
the same thing going to happen is this
gonna benefit all of us or just the very
rich who get there first
what yes bail space and not just SpaceX
but the whole privatization well I think
in order to create a self-sustaining
city on Mars
you've got to make it as affordable as
possible to go there all those you work
get enough people yeah so I think you've
got to get the cost of moving to Mars
roughly equivalent to a middle-class
home and then there'd be enough people
who wanted to sell their house on earth
and move to Mars I think that's sort of
a key threshold for to become a
self-sustaining colony if you will kind
of like the the English colonies in the
Americas you know which started out with
a lot of sort of
you know basically rich people and the
British government sponsoring people to
go over and then but eventually you know
anyone could go over so it's the same
sort of thing as you know in the UK
Richard Branson with Virgin Galactic you
do you sort of see that as you're doing
a similar thing that we're pretty
different from Virgin Galactic what do
you guys do sort of more oriented
towards entertainment you know and
having a sort of a quick fun ride so now
I serious is SpaceX yeah it's right I
mean SpaceX was sort of more Martian
colonization whereas Virgin Galactic at
least in its initial efforts is is sort
of trying to give you kind of five
minutes of weight weightlessness you
know it's different different thing
they're great and last question this
happens a lot I'm sure but there's
always the Tony Stark comparison that's
made and Jon Favreau said alright you're
an inspiration to that and I read that
you sort of read comics growing up
yeah and in South Africa do you ever see
yourself as a bit of a superhero is that
what you think I'm not really know
now I mean I think of myself as sort of
a ninja as an engineer really try to
create new technology that's that's
that's important and but fun and cool at
the same time it's a very tiny star
cancer you know mask thank you very much
all right